there is a natural force within the
capitalist when there's no monopolies
uh of competition being the
accountability so if you're a shitty
boss
the employ the employee in the capital
system has the freedom to move to
another company work for a better boss
so that that creates pressure on the
employers and the bosses that's at least
the idea that you uh there's two
boundaries of you not misbehaving one is
the law so regulatory regulations by
passed by the government democratic and
the second is
because there's always alternatives
in theory
then that puts pressure on everyone to
behave well because you can always leave
so i mean that's kinds of accountability
but what you're saying is that does not
result in any in a significant enough
accountability where the employer
uh that avoids exploitation of the
worker absolutely i mean whatever
accountability you get in those
mechanisms and
let me respond to that and then on the
counter argument
um
first competition
here again we have to be hegelians just
a little
competition
destroys itself
it doesn't need any out the whole point
of competition is to beat the other guy
if i can produce the same product as the
other guy
either a better quality or a lower price
or maybe both
then i win because the customers will
come to me because my price is lower or
my quality is better and they'll leave
the other guy he'll go out of business
now let's follow when he goes out of
business because i've won the
competition
he fires his workers
i hire them because i'm now going to be
able to serve a market he can't serve
anymore so i'm gonna i'm gonna buy the
used equipment i'm gonna
and thereby many
become few
monopoly is the product of competition
it's not the antithesis
it's the product
well
let's see that's where it comes from
well there's another there's another
element to the system where there's
always a new guy that comes in
uh there isn't there isn't well that's
the that's the dream the entrepreneurial
spirit of a free
uh you know of of the united states for
example of a capitalist system is
uh you can
be
broke
and one day have a strong idea and build
up a business that takes on google and
facebook and twitter
and uh all the different
car ford gm which is what you know you
look at tesla for example right that's
the american dream uh one of the many
ideals of the american dream is you can
um
uh move
from
dirt poor to being the richest person in
the world right and um
it can happen it can happen but you're
you know what that's like that's like
you can win the lottery no that's not
quite no the lottery is complete luck
here you can work your ass off if you
have a good larger better in the lottery
that's not that's not true there's a lot
of new businesses how many teslas do you
do you know that's a really bad example
because the car company the
automotive sector is so difficult
to uh they operate as such a thin margin
of profit
they're probably a good example of like
capitalism just completely coming to a
halt in terms of lack of innovation
because you know
that's a very complicated industry
because of the supply chain there's so
much come on
they have their uniquenesses you're
quite right
but so does every other industry the one
thing that's common is that many become
few
what you can also have is when you have
a few
they jack up the price they make an
enormous profit and in the irony of
capitalism marx would love this they
begin to
incentivize people to break into this
industry because the few remaining are
making a wild amount of profit because
they are a few and can [ __ ] the market
to make it work like that for them
so the reason every
every small capitalist is trying to
build market share that's a police way
polite way of saying they want to become
a monopolist or to be more exact an
oligopolist one of a handful of firms
that dominates that's what they're there
for but yeah to push back a little bit
also because that's
could be
this is a question also do you think
we're in danger of oversimplifying
capitalism
it completely removes the basic decency
of human beings
so if you give me a choice
to press to press a button
to get rid of the competition and that
but that's going to lead to a lot of
suffering there's a lot of people at the
heads of companies that won't press that
button
that it's not in the calculation it's
not just money
it's human well-being too
so like
i think
i
yes
you and i don't live in the same place
then so you're saying that the forces of
capitalism take over the minds of the
people at the top you got it and then
they they seized being human essentially
no there's the basic okay i wouldn't i
wouldn't
depending on your model of humans yeah
but they they lose track of the better
angels of their nature
and uh they just become cogs in the
machine but there just happened to be
the company i would put it differently
that the system is so set up it's a
little bit like natural selection the
guys who may own i could say the women
too it doesn't matter the people who
make it up through the layers of the
bureaucracy and get to the top in these
things have had to do things along the
way that become selective if they can't
stand it because they have that human
quality and there are people like i've
known them
they're the ones running an airbnb in in
vermont
they che they went there and they said
i'm not doing this anymore i'm not going
to treat people like that i'm going to
make a lovely place in vermont with my
husband or my wife or whatever and i'm
going to be you know enjoying the people
that come by and be a decent of course
of course
but the system selects
the firm you know if you don't do what
has to be done to make the profit go up
you're toast there anyway the rest of
the people who vote for you are going to
kick you out you can tell them all day
long what a lovely person you are then
they're going to look at you and wonder
what happened to you how did you even
get this far with the lovely person
horseshoe it's not okay okay okay okay
it's not necessarily just a lovely
person so maybe
my i'll just say my bias is the people i
know
are especially at the top of companies
or in the tech sector
where
innovation
is such a big part of it
so i think a lot of the things we're
talking about is when there's not much
innovation in the system
so
innovation usually comes in the history
of capitalism innovation comes in spurts
there's the electric period the
chemistry period the nuclear period
there's now whatever you want to call it
the artificial intelligence or robotics
or computer it doesn't it comes and then
there's a flurry as everything is
reorganized around whatever the newest
technology is and then you have a period
where you can get excited about that and
the very rich people who come to the top
can talk endlessly as they always do
about innovation
but again you know it it really is this
is a recurring
kind
uh
of debate and a recurring kind of issue
for me
how do i put this in a way
that
no i don't mean to offend so
please please no no i don't i don't want
to but
the problem with capitalism is
and maybe you'll like this the problem
with capitalism is
not that it is the one thing that's
consistent with human nature that's what
its defenders would like to have us
believe
but if anything i would argue the
opposite
that it is such a contradiction
to parts of our nature not other parts
that there it can never quite make it
there's always going to be the people
who don't go along with it people you're
talking about who do quit along the way
or maybe a few of them actually
make it to the top by god knows
what hook or what crook that they did it
but most of them go
and you know why because their humanity
is contradicted
by what it is they're being asked
to do
i mean the the corporate sector this
year just to give you an idea
ceos uh are
jacking up their
their wage package they're already out
of whack i mean the average ceo pay is
now three three hundred times what the
average worker pays but they're jacking
it up even more why because that's
what's happening in their universe
that's what they're all doing it and
they have to do each one of them
justifies that i have to do that
otherwise i'd lose my guide to the next
one which of course is true but there's
no comfort for the mass of people who
aren't ceos for whom this argument isn't
very exciting
so
there are
they're doing that at a time when the
american people can't cope they've just
gone through the covet disaster they've
gone through the worst second worst
economic crash of capitalism in our
history
after two years of this one-two punch
they got an inflation
a third punch and we are now predicting
rising interest rates in a recession at
the end of the year or early next year
you can't do this to a working class
when this was done to the german worker
class in the 1920s hitler was the result
you keep doing that in this country
we're already watching it you're going
to get that too you're already getting
bits and pieces you can't she's
suffering amidst the working class
that's growing taking out on it can turn
to anger some little 18 year old kid who
has to go
three hours in his car and blow away
people in a supermarket
and it happens every day in this country
every day
so
that anger rises up in those little ways
now and bigger
potentially
by the way there's one more thing
on the rationality and this goes to elon
musk
if you're interested 49 000 people were
killed in automobile
accidents this last year the number was
just released yesterday
49 000.
automobiles are the single largest
pollutant in the country they use up an
enormous amount of energy
they uh they use up enormous in our
resources
there is a way to make transportation
much more rational and we've known it
for decades it's called mass
transportation it's a really beautifully
maintained crystal clear clean frequent
system of buses trains street rock
trolleys uh vans
it could easily be done in this society
in fact i once did a project that i
estimated cost 30 billion dollars
that's less than we're sending to
ukraine
to do this to reconfigure it uh a public
transit system where everywhere in this
country all the major metropolis this
country's overwhelmingly metropolitan
area well it
really has to be more than 30 billion
but but well it was a few years ago
you're saying it's but i'm using a lot
of that's insane right it's not crazy
stuff it's a reasonable number right
right hey listen um but there's a and
we'll let me just finish the point sure
yes okay
so
i'm trying to be rational here
if we have a climate crisis which
everyone tells me we do
if it's got a lot to do with fossil
fuels which everybody tells me it has to
do
and and with the use of the fossil fuel
particularly for the automobile then the
solution to the problem would be mass
transit
we don't we're doing nothing to make
that happen nothing
well there's you know on
you could argue that autonomous vehicles
is a kind of public transit because it's
going to be reusable vehicles it will
end
in theory uh car ownership so you just
have a more kind of distributed public
transit if it happens but you know that
that's a side effect his major goal and
the major goal of the other companies
that are busy
squeezing to get his share pie smaller
so they have some for general motors
toyota all of them are making electric
cars though
so what they've done is they've replaced
the individual car with fossil fuel
with another individual car yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts what are you doing it's one
of the things they're doing but
automation is also another one but on
the elon side there's also
hilariously named boring company yes
which is working on tunnels which is
actually expanding the
the the the flexibility you might have
to start playing with ideas of public
transit i think listen i'm now partially
living in austin texas that i don't know
if they know what a public transit
system is period yes um there's most
americans pick up trucks yeah they're
well there's this is an interesting
so
the older by the way footnote the older
the city the more likely it has public
transportation
so you're saying boston is the best
example yes you have you been well yeah
yeah of course yeah i have a place in
boston boston with the street railway
boston is your case study of how to do
this because they've been doing it all
along new york's pretty good too there's
a trade-off yeah new york i would say is
better than boston because so there's
you know
their technology also helps you out to
do the public transit better uh
it's almost like boston is a little too
old but yes i get your point
you